academic life in the United States
especially in the last I'll say five
years as Jonathan hate and others have
noted has has really really been damaged
by a culture of what used to be called
political correctness but I don't think
it that quite captures is of fundamental
intolerance of a deep in liberalism and
deep hostility to free debate and free
inquiry that is is killing the great
institutions of American academia so
yeah I mean I I'm as proud as it could
be of being an American but I'm I'm at
the same time depressed by some of the
trends that I see in the country today
because they seem so at odds with the
first principles of American life did
you notice a difference on the academic
side when you were with intellectuals
the way European intellectuals would
perhaps talk about something versus the
way Americans did or different maybe a
different focus or anything like that
well you know I think there is a
disappointment which I need to admit to
I came to the United States believing
that American universities were the
places where the biggest intellects had
the biggest arguments and that that was
part of the appeal of Harvard I I admit
there was this sense that Oxford and
Cambridge had been the great
universities of the 19th and 20th
century but now in the 21st century you
really wanted to be at Harvard and I
think over time it was a slow process I
became disillusioned with the American
Academy and I found that it was becoming
less and less hospitable to the kind of
rambunctious free inquiry that motivates
me and now I've reached the point where
I look back nostalgically on the Oxford
of the 1980s where there was simply no
question of of your free speech being
circumscribes
the contrary in the 1980s we kind of
found ourselves constantly pushing the
boundaries of what could be said as
undergraduates we found our professors
were intellectually an extraordinarily
diverse bunch there were the die-hard
Marxists the kind of Eric Hobsbawm types
and then there were the high Tories the
Jeremy catters and it was a tremendously
enriching experience academic life in
the United States especially in the last
I'll say five years as Jonathan hate and
others have noted has has really really
been damaged by a culture of what used
to be called political correctness but I
don't think it that quite captures is of
fundamental intolerance of a deep in
liberalism and deep hostility to free
debate and free inquiry that is is
killing the great institutions of
American academia so yeah I mean I am as
proud as it could be of being an
American but I'm I'm at the same time
depressed by some of the trends that I
see in the country today because they
seem so at odds with the first
principles of American life is it weird
for you to see this spread across the
world at the same time because last year
when I was at Oxford and I got to speak
at Oxford Union which I still it sort of
feels like a dream that I even got to
speak there but just being there and
being around the hundreds of years of
history and walking around and you feel
this this thing that that you guys have
that we have much less of obviously
because of the breadth of history you
feel this this generation after
generation of caring about knowledge and
history and all of these things and even
just in the last couple days I've seen
these articles that Oxford there are
professors pushing to have more lenient
grades for students of color and just
the rest of the sort of what I would
call intellectual rot that we've seen
across these these schools it must be
particularly painful for you to see it
happen at a place like Oxford I think so
although I sometimes get the sense
that's
that it's not that deep the rotten in
Oxford for example I was very pleased
that the vice-chancellor Louise
Richardson and other leaders of the
university dismissed again the calls to
tear down a statue of sessile Rhodes
that stands in oral College Cambridge I
think has been rather more inclined to
appease these forces of iconoclasm it is
iconoclasm the tearing down of statues
and I
I know that I'm a conservative when I
see statues being torn down and a little
part of me winces it doesn't really much
matter who the statue is I prefer
statues to be built and and I think
Oxford has has held the line there thus
far but as is always the case there are
elements within any academic society
that lets see opportunities in the
ideologies of workers see ways in which
they can advance their own careers by
championing these outlandish and
illiberal ideas the the great danger is
that it becomes a norm that a university
should be intellectually homogeneous
that that we should pursue every kind of
diversity except intellectual and
ideological diversity and and I worry
that eventually what what has been
happening at American universities will
overcome the healthier forces in Oxford
and Cambridge that's not to say that
that could we couldn't do more at these
universities to make them attractive to
and appealing to people from minority
communities and from the white working
class which is notably underrepresented
at these places but the mistake that's
always made in these debates is to think
that the problem lies with the
universities rather than with the
systems of education that simply
discourage students or make them unable
to apply it to elite institutions I've
always said I believe passionately in
educational opportunity and the social
mobility that it creates my parents were
the first in their
families to go to university and what I
see in the United States and in the UK
are failing schools that don't allow
talented young people whether they're
from minority communities or from the
working class to get anywhere close to
applying to elite universities that's
what we need to fix and there are lots
of ways of doing it but one doesn't hear
those discussed so I know we could spend
you know eight hours days dissecting
woke nests and and the rest of it but I
want to shift from it a little bit but I
just have one other question on the woke
things since we've treaded into those
waters as a conservative academic you
were obviously and we talked about a
little bit about this last time on the
outside of what most sort of academic
circles you know sort of think is
acceptable even even in historical in
history Department do you think that
conservatives have a better defense
against woke miss than liberals so for
example John hate who I've had on the
show and and many of the other academics
that you know that that I've talked to
that come from the more liberal side I
sense that they all though they're
making good arguments I don't think they
have good defenses against this because
of the sort of openness of liberalism
that it's being used against itself and
I do sense that conservatism as a
worldview or as a philosophical lens
does have some protections that
liberalism doesn't do you agree with
that well it's true that that we
wouldn't be in quite this situation if
it hadn't been for liberal professors
giving jobs to progressive professors
who then gave jobs to Marxists and
cultural Marxists
I mean conservative academic
conservative professor these are
becoming oxymorons because there are so
few conservatives left and the American
Academy I mean that the figures are
clear it's not like this is an old
problem that we've always had over time
the ratio of registered Democrats to
Republicans has risen steadily to the
point that you can't calculate it in
some departments because there are zero
Republicans and I think that that trend
broadly is explicable because liberals
felt that they should hire people to the
left of them under estimating the extent
to which those people would
fundamentally differ on the the
principles of say the project of
historical scholarship it is not the
goal of a history department to impose
on the past the ideals of the
progressives of 2020 that's the ultimate
condescension to the past conservatives
have understood better I think the
dangers and and the tragedy has been
that conservatives have been poorly
organized I mean the extinction of
conservatives in say history departments
isn't just the fault of liberals hiring
progressives it's also that the
conservatives did poorly when it came to
the most basic organization that has to
happen in academia the patronage
networks at getting your students into
good positions I don't think
conservatives were very good at that my
conservative mentors were wonderful
intellectuals people like Norman stone
but Norman would not be remembered I
think for his his organizational skills
for his writing certainly but but
definitely not for his his deafness
academic politics so it's partly I think
because conservatives were rather too
busy writing books and perhaps
occasionally drinking bottles of wine
and not working hard enough at the
committee stages to make sure that the
right candidates got hired if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist there all
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell